tony aujourd'hui donc on va parler de
sexe de sextoys et de plein d'autres
affaires c'est le fun donc premièrement
est ce qu'il ya des gens dans la sphère
qui savent qu est ce qu un déshonneur
industriel lever la main à ceux qui
savent qu'est ce qu'un dessin industriel
lever la main ceux qui pensent qu'on
fait des plans et qu'on dessine des
usines non c'est bon pour vous je vais
juste vous mettre un peu dans le bain
pour vous décrire qu'est ce qu'un
designer industriel parce que ça va vous
expliquer quel est mon point de vue sur
les jouets érotiques donc un designer
industriel c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
sur tout ce qui est l'interaction entre
un objet est une personne ou si
maintenant on travaille aussi sur les
services une personne c'est à dire que
comme vous voyez la ferrari passer dans
la rue qui vous avez un petit chez nous
c'est le désengagement industriel qui a
travaillé dessus pourquoi est ce que
vous êtes en amour avec votre mac ou
votre iphone
c'est le désert industriel tout ce qui
est bon dans la vie ça vient du désert
industriel
donc j'ai commencé mon bac en dessin
industriel puis bon on fait plein de 5 à
7 de choses le fon arrive une soirée ont
fait une soirée de topware sextoys c'est
à dire que vous avez une vendeuse qui
vient à la maison que vous êtes avec vos
amis du vin puis elle représente tout ce
qui est des sextos et dégaine des yeux
la massage des choses comme ça puis bon
la soirée avance prend de 3 coupes de
vin mais and incumbent d'acheter un
sextoy gg 20 ans puis bon je me dit en
cash le sextoy je vais m'acheter un
scoop c'est encore du plaisir votre
plaisir à deux noms qui me convient
d'acheter mon premier sextoy de coupe
qui est un anneau vibrant à conquereuil
avec un dauphin mouse dessus
je paye 45 d'alors pour ça j'arrive à la
maison puis je me dis bon ça doit être
pas super je monte ça monte comme pense
pas au conseil
puis bon je me dis je l'ouvré autres
j'ai quand même p 45 dollars je peux
l'utiliser tout ce qui s'y joue ce déjà
dit les emballages et il faut 3 exacto
pour l'ouvrir parce qu'il entre au
plastique c'est déjà moins fort chez le
louvre la texture
c'est particulier ça fait trente
secondes qui est en dehors de
l'emballage déjà la poussière colle
dessus
y comme boucliers des bulles dedans
comme vous pouvez le voir sur l'anatomie
du bon dauphin faut que vous rentriez le
petit générateur ils votent blanc
derrière du dauphin dans une petit
interstice pour vibrer puis le tout est
attaché après une manette avec un film
fait en action jouée après la manette
puis en plus de tous ces beaufs
culturisme il s'orne
c'est vraiment pas agréable plus je me
dis je suis descendant industriel mais
en fait je commence que je me dis quand
même quelque chose qui marche po aix
c'est vraiment pas sexy puis ça me tente
vraiment pas d'avoir une soirée sexy
avec ce genre d'objet leur nom je me dis
tout apprendre même avec les jouets
érotiques
pour moi jouer aux côtés de couple ça
devrait faire penser à quelque chose
comme ça ça devrait être lumineuse
s'annonce joyeux ça devrait à la limite
un petit peu drôle mais pas mal à l'aise
en puis donc je me dis ok mon bac avance
puis à la fin de mon bac je décide de me
spécialiser je fais tellement de gens
que ces jouets érotiques tout les jours
pourquoi pas me spécialiser là dedans
donc je m'en vais dans le domaine des
jouets érotiques et après trois ans de
recherche puisque là ça fait trois ans
je me suis spécialisé donc moment mon
truc de départ c'étaient les jouets
érotiques et vans la notion d'intimité
et de romance dans le couple on s'entend
un dauphin move c'est pas votre idée
d'une soirée remontée que c'est pas la
mienne non plus mais après trois ans de
recherche est d'abord fondé
m'accompagner dans le tout je me rends
compte
il ya peut-être pas ce qui est bon la
notion romance puis d'intimité dans nos
coupes de nos jours donc c'est un peu le
truc que je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
on va commencer par les libérateurs
parce que c'est ma spécialité pour vous
maintenant une bande de l'invention du
vibrateur en 1801 on invente un proto
une prothèse anti masturbation ça c'est
pour vous mettre dans le bain comment
est ce qu'on pense à cette époque lui de
la sexualité
70 ans plus tard on invente le vibrateur
ils sont pas ou viré sur indices insee
pas la société qui a fait maintenant la
masturbation c'est bien non c'est le
premier jour à port est alimentée pour
contrer l'hystérie féminine qui était
une maladie mentale chez les femmes qui
dès que vous aviez des gros en bourse
qui après votre homme crie après vos
enfants a décidé de lui faire la
vaisselle
tout est hystérique
comment est-ce qu'on régler ce problème
là l'époque on faisait une stimulation
manuel par un docteur parce que c'est
une maladie le docteur stimulation
manuel aujourd'hui qu'on appelle
masturbation jusqu'au paroxysme de
l'hystérie féminine ou orgasme c'est
comme vous voulez en d2 paroxysme en gaz
même chose puis on s'entend avec 25
cliente par jour le pauvre medecin
commencé à voir madame on a donc inventé
le vibrateur j'aimerais vous compreniez
toute la complexité à cornèze fini avec
ça vous avez un moteur à vapeur avec des
poulies
tu viens dans vos challenges en tout cas
ça devrait marcher pour longtemps après
on a continué à mentir comme un outil d
aide médicale ça s'est vendu dans le
catalogue sears vient acheter votre
machine akoun votre ventilateur produits
bretons s'étaient toutes dans le même
package sans même page puis bon avec le
temps les générateurs les gens les
gosses sont rendus compte que la main du
plaisir et que ceux qui sont dispo cool
on va enlever sa du mainstream
éventuellement s'étaler dans les
sex-shops et tranquillement pas vite ses
revenus bon sens pas tout le monde de
nos jours entendu parler d'un jeu le
rappeur une place ou en cire devenu
mainstream surtout en 2009 comme ça fait
son apparition dans sex and the city
avec l'autre habite maintenant on a même
des applications de sextoys et comble du
plaisir on a le sextoy jedi je vous
présente ici un sextoy qui en plus de
vibrer et met des petits rayons laser
sur votre intérieur pour stimuler la
circulation sanguine
donc tant qu'à être dans les temps les
jobs de jedi comme je me suis dit voici
un lightsaber pour beaucoup de plaisir
on est rendus jusque là dans les six
taureaux les sextoys c'est au jour plus
de moteurs plus de vibrations vos
batteries vont durer plus longtemps si
vous êtes ceux qui marchent plus fort on
vole ploguer dans meurs c'est toujours
plus plus plus que ça soit une vibration
de vibrations là on fait point
j'imaginais clitoridien - j'imagine
anav vous êtes sûr que votre cerveau est
en haut à droite puis c'est toujours
plus moi ce que j'appelle une notion de
performance
c'est à dire on voulait simplement un
orgasme on vous en mettront en quatre
minutes
c'est beau s'il vous lemaitre passa
board organisme de garantie 4 mai lot
donc pour moi c'est la notion de
performance que j'ai tous les jours dans
ma business
puis je me dis on pourrait peut être
revenir à l'époque où est ce que les
jouets retient une petite animation les
jouets érotiques était une ride
une aide soit à l'éducation sexuelle où
est la masturbation la découverte de soi
ça a déjà existé ça c'est un instinct
des dépressions dans les grottes de
glasgow où l'on sente un peu juste quand
on ne sait pas toujours été leur puis il
y avait d'autres moyens que d'y aller
car moteur 46 chevaux pour avoir votre
orgasme
donc ça c'est ma fiction que je connais
le plus mais avec le temps j'ai
découvert aussi qu'il ya le problème dit
pas sexualisation ce je peux m'asseoir
que tout le monde hommes dans la salle 2
déjà expérimenté vous voyez des faits
tout nu d'un arrêt d'autobus tout les
jours puis ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
aussi le phénomène d'objets je vais y
arriver
objectif ication de la femme et du foot
- souvent comme vous dites
hyper sexualisation première chose qui
me vient en tête si une pub de chars
avec une fille à moitié tout nu puis
c'est souvent à ce qu'on voit mais ça
existe aussi chez les femmes c'est à
dire que au lieu de remplacer votre vote
à chaud par une belle fille à moitié
tonus et pour une feuille c'est
tellement dur d'avoir une relation et
des hauts et des bas pourquoi pagis
allez vous acheter un bon coup de la
gaine date des pépites de chocolat
coulis de caramel et occident salchaud
qui ont salué juste à ma description de
la gamme base puis c'est ce qu'on fait
c'est au lieu de mettre du temps et de
l'énergie sur vos relations humaines
acheter un bon pot de crème glacée ou
des bonnes pâtes puis ça va remplacer
votre relation même si tout le monde
plus facile c'est beaucoup moins
d'entretien qu'une blonde ou autre chose
puis ça c'est pas la bride personnes
s'étant joints facile
l'hypersexualisation tellement facile
que le guide restos voir est tombé en
plein dedans
cette année c'est les 18 ans du cadref
thobois enfin qui sont dit on va y aller
a duré seulement
puis ça a fait un tollé sur internet
mais pourtant c'est pas la seule
solution
en fait dès que vous faites quelque
chose qui est pas sexuel pouvait faire
des pubs sexuelle et sa force si vous
êtes quelqu'un qui fait des produits ou
des services de nature sexuelle peut pas
faire de publicité à connotation
sexuelle ça passe juste pas dans la
société
bon exemple ici vous avez eu point qui
fait une campagne pour développer
justement d'aider les publicités family
friendly
c'est génial et noté c'est excellent
puis vous voyez moi dans mon domaine je
peux pas faire de pub ou est-ce qu'on
voit des gens sont touchés parce que je
fais des jouets sa pop puisse quand même
étonnant mais je pense qu'on est capable
de faire des pubs pour vendre des
compagnies qui vont aller chercher des
valeurs et de l'empathie
oui on peut avoir des gens nus sur un
écran comme les publicités de dove qui
mettent des femmes très bien dans leur
corps à l'écran je passe super bien il
faut juste ça vaut bien le faire
en plus du phénomène de sex-toys on a un
phénomène qui est la désinformation que
vous allez me dire comment on entend
parler tous les jours de fête des
journaux c'est vrai on en parlait tous
les jours de 500 journaux dans les
magazines ecce terra
mais tout ce qu on va vous parler c'est
des statistiques une femme sur trois
n'est pas fan de fellation ça n'en fait
pas beaucoup dans seules les femmes
préfèrent la nourriture au sexe clame
avec la pub d'arghandab les hommes les
femmes aiment les hommes italiens
enfin pour ça des amis se masturber tous
les jours on peut augmenter le
pourcentage et parle même pas de
masturbation féminine ici pourquoi les
femmes demande-t-elle plus que les
hommes oui c'est de l'information sur
c'est ce que je retrouve dans mon
journal
puis après ça on se dit bon tu peux
avoir un esprit critique doit quand même
eu de l'information à l'école
imaginez-vous des fois en amérique du
nord encore c'est des bonnes soeurs qui
donnent de l'éducation sexuelle dans
certaines contrées reculées et beaucoup
d'expérience
ils vont parler d'abstinence je tapais
devrait faire apprécier ils vont me
parler au mieux port du condom maladies
transmises sexuellement plus de passé et
apprennent ça 16 ans de jeux et d'un
petit peu de temps puis toute ta vie
d'adulte toute ta vie sexuelle jusqu'à
85 cents ans entendre le la bisexuelle
s'arrête pas à 42 une photo ménopause
jusque là jusqu'à la feuille d'avis et
les seules informations pratiques qu'on
va donner mais il ya des revenus dans le
monde qui existent pour vous informer en
norvège en trop qui donne des cours
d'éducation sexuelle
à partir de 8 ans jusqu'à 18 ans il
couvre toutes les domaines que ce soit
les i ts les les les jeunes femmes
enceintes trop tôt que ce soit vos
rapports une partenaire comment est ce
qu'après cinquante se retient la flamme
sexuelle il couvre tous ont dansé collé
et aussi les initiatives dans les
sections ils vont vous donner plus
d'informations les vendeurs vont être
formés pour vous dire que tu veux tel
jour ne vivra pas pourquoi ok on peut
travailler là dessus
ils vont même faire des ateliers comme
il ya une cause à toronto qui fait des
ateliers d'éjaculation féminine comment
est-ce qu'on travaille l'éjaculation
féminine puis un peu comme dans l'esprit
de ce matin avec funky on peut aussi
retourner aux sources
à l'époque la sexualité était intrigué
avec la spiritualité vous alliez dans un
temple hindou
puis vous avez du monde fait du kama
sutra c'est sûr vous allez poser des
questions à vos parents les jeux c'est
mûr se fonder des mi mouche
vous allez amorcé un début de
conversation
donc si on regarde un peu en rapport ces
trois ces trois aspects là dans votre
cerveau ce qui a réussi au fil du temps
vous allez vous poser des questions
ok j'aime pas faire une fellation est ce
que je te corps est blonde on n'a pas eu
de regards simultanées ça veut tout dire
qu'on n'ait pas fait l'un pour l'autre
puis qu'on finira pas nos jours ensemble
j'ai pas trouvé son point je vais te
dire que je t'aime mauvaise chose puis
c'est une des questions qui nous
reviennent puis on est calme habitude
voire standard que la seule question qui
me vient en tête c'est est-ce que je
normal est-ce que je normal des messages
est-ce que je normal que j'aime pas ça
puis c'est une question qui est tout le
temps n'a rien de votre cerveau votre
code unienne faut de temps en temps puis
c'est la question aussi qui a amené elle
freine qui dit qui est le premier
sexologue a débuté le film le domaine de
la sexologie
legault était biologiste puis est assez
ouvert donc ces étudiants venaient tout
le temps de poser des questions écoute
je fais soft normal je sais pas je fais
ça tu normal je sais pas puis à l'époque
faut que je vous mettre un peu dans les
mentalités de l'époque sonne donc
masturbe hate you go blind un petit
souci en dessous même pas mourir c'est à
dire que la masturbation c'est très mal
vues plongeantes juste de masturbation
masculine la masturbation féminine
ça n'existe pas puis c'était tellement
mal vu à l'époque tout ce qui était
sexuelle le code sexuelle se limiter au
mariage si vous avez une vie sexuelle
c'est quand vous êtes marié de vous êtes
blanc 3 vous êtes hétérosexuels c'est
tout ce que vous avez à savoir sur la
sexualité à l'époque donc qui nous est
le seul moyen qu'ils ont trouvé pour
amener la sexualité sur le domaine
public et en jaser c'est via les
statistiques le problème
bon les statistiques qui peut y aller
surtout avec les habitudes sexuelles et
les organes génitaux un peu ce que
master & johnson ont fait peu en fait
des recherches au niveau des organes
génitaux problème c'est que c'est le
seul ce discours qui respecte et puis
les soixante dix dernières années on
parle encore que la sexualité ce n'est
qu'au niveau des organes génitaux ce
n'est qu'un truc reproducteurs les
jouets érotiques c'est la même chose
les jouets érotiques qui m'ont juste
ciblés comme les quatre que vous avez
vus ils vont juste cible et je vous
organes génitaux
ils vont pas vous dire que
le font le plaisir sexuel c'est 80%
psychologique
moi je me dis aujourd'hui qu'on est dû
pour un changement de paradigme
on est due pour changer la conversation
arrêter de parler de cette cité les
statistiques c'est juste contraignant
ça nous met pas une barrière ça nous
oblige dans une norme il est temps qu'on
parle de qu'est ce qu'on ressent au
niveau de la sexualité que ce soit avec
vos partenaires ou comment est-ce que
vous en parlez avec vos enfants puis est
un con qu'on comprenne que la sexualité
c'est vraiment pas juste biologique pas
juste pour la reproduction
je pense qu'on l'a compris un petit
butin c'est aussi avec les émotions dans
le couple comment est ce que ça
fonctionne plus aussi le cerveau qu'est
ce qui donne du plaisir à votre cerveau
qu'est-ce qui vous excite entendre
personne puis j'aimerais vraiment qu'on
commence à en discuter plus sur les
assauts sur les médias sociaux
moi j'en parle tous les jours ces médias
sociaux mais j'en fais une business mais
que vous aussi vous en parler sur les
médias sociaux que vous amenez la
discussion puis donc j'aimerais vraiment
qu'en sortant si mon but aujourd'hui
c'est de vous faire parler de sexe afin
de la journée ça va être le fun au
cocktail avec du vin gratuit
mais ce soit vraiment juste en parler
puis je sais que c'est gênant bon moi
j'ai pu vraiment la jungle mais je sais
que c'est gênant de parler de sexualité
donc je vous propose un voire deux
retiennent que moi j'adore qui vont vous
donner des munitions pour parler
sexuelle des pions des meilleurs moyens
pour commencer une conversation en
sexualité c'est d'aller vous informer de
les lire d'aller écouter des choses peut
en discuter avec vos pairs proche
famille par an et sur ceux j'aimerais
vous laisser sur une petite citation et
marvin wording si ce que vous aimez vous
et votre partenaire non pas dans la
norme mais c'est ce que vous aimez
protein enfants comme ça et pas de
problème merci pour votre attention